hey 42 here if you have the chance to
live on an active volcano floating in
the ocean in the middle of nowhere that
erupts on a regular basis and where the
air is so toxic that you are required to
wear a gas mask
would you take up this wonderful
opportunity no what's wrong with you the
two and a half thousand happy residents
of my akhi islands have nothing but good
words to say about their cozy little
home look they are practically welcoming
you with open arms
known to the Japanese as mayor Kazuma
this island volcano last erupted in June
2000 after a 17-year along the island
resident volcano is called Mount om and
she is one hell of a violent mother in
the year 2000 not only did she a rock
with full force sending ash plumes 10
miles high into the air but the eruption
also caused over seventeen and a half
thousand subsequent earthquakes which
lasted for a month these earthquakes
caused major cracks in the Earth's crust
beneath the island several craters also
collapsed causing major rifts in the
ground ever since these huge tears in
the volcano have constantly released
highly toxic sulfur dioxide into the air
this caused a whole twenty percent of
the islands to become uninhabitable
immediately afterwards the Islanders
have always had issues with sulfur
dioxide being released from the volcano
and gas masks are not a new thing for
the island but this drastic event made
matters a whole lot worse so the
Japanese government quickly took action
and evacuated the entirety of the island
residents they banned them from their
homes for the next five years for this
entire time the island was declared
off-limits to anyone and everyone
turning it into a ghost town resembling
Chernobyl mount IMO continued releasing
over 20,000 tons of sulfur dioxide every
day over a few years the poisonous gases
started to calm down slightly and
eventually in 2005 the evacuation order
was lifted and people were finally
permitted to go back to their
however the constant release of toxic
gases from the volcano hadn't stopped
and it still hasn't to this day so
surely people didn't return to their
homes knowing that they would return to
a level of constant pollution that could
drastically shorten their lives
no 2,800 residents chose to return to
the island the few that didn't remained
in their Tokyo homes that were given to
them when they were evacuated but most
did return
I guess the drawer of what was once your
home never really goes away but there
was a residents returning to the island
were required to carry gas masks with
them at all times they are not required
to always wear them although it is
strongly advised since the pollution
levels all over the island are still
highly toxic if the sulfur dioxide level
suddenly rise to fatal levels an alarm
is sounded across the entire island and
all residents must immediately equip
their masks on top of all this a whole
two thirds of the islands are still
completely off-limits today due to
extremely high toxicity levels the
government conduct regular health checks
on all the islands residents to ensure
that tickety-boo
despite the omnipresent cloud of
murderous gaps
what's even more crazy than wanting to
live in this environment is that the
island now has a thriving tourist trade
Japanese mainlanders and occasionally
foreigners flocked to the island in
their thousands every year to take tours
of abandoned houses and more a perennial
favorite is a visit to a school that was
half destroyed by love of course
disposable gas masks are sold to
tourists at local stores all over the
island
I guess it's quite the adrenaline rush
to explore somewhere that could kill you
if you breathed in the air for a little
too long so now you've learned of all
the wonders at this little killer island
has to offer have you reconsidered would
you live on miyajima island if for some
bizarre reason your answer is still yes
then I'll leave you with this thought
due to the sulphur dioxide present in
the air the entire island smells of
farts 24/7 thanks for watching you've
heard a snake charming
you may have even hypnotized a chicken
but I bet you've never heard of worm
charming do you worry about a zombie
uprising well fear not the US Department
of Defense has you covered the Pentagon
has created a comprehensive plan
detailing how to counter a zombie
apocalypse